Sub wise, crack Jared here. My love for the original matrix is no secret,
but I can't deny that I found the last two films pretty baffling.
You might've seen our previous videos covering what went wrong with my favorite
franchise, but given the announcement of a fourth matrix film,
I want it to look at the series with fresh eyes.
This was driven by one specific comment from [inaudible] and a variety article
announcing the new installment.
She said many of the ideas Lily and I explored 20 years ago about our reality
are even more relevant. Now, what does she mean by that?
Is it because robots are stealing?
Our jobs are dusters coming back in style is Elon Musk talking about being
trapped in a simulation again,
while all of these might hold some kernel of truth,
especially the part about how cool dusters are.
We think we figured out what the,
which house sees we're trying to do and why it may resonate today more than ever
like the title of the rage against the machine song that closes the film.
The original is about waking up.
[Inaudible].
About seeing past the wool that has been pulled over our eyes of shattering the
grand illusion. While it might've been a little obscured by weird rave scenes,
we can better understand the latter two films with the question of what's next.
Once we've become awaken to the true reality behind the lies of the world.
What other dangers lurk behind the red pill? And how does this speak to today?
Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on the matrix is real freedom possible.
And as always spoilers ahead for all three matrix films,
but first a very brief recap,
the original matrix follows hacker Neo as he learns that the world is a digital
illusion and that machines have created a vast simulation in order to use
humanity as a renewable energy source.
Neo joins the human resistance in the real world.
And after some self-reflection realizes his destiny as the one,
a prophesied super bad-ass who will use his powers to free humanity from the
matrix in the matrix reloaded,
no such liberation has happened because it turns out the one is nothing more
than an inevitable anomaly in the system that the machines have planned for.
In other words,
Neo's exceptionalism is just part of the greater project to keep the human race
enslaved. At the end of the film,
Neo makes a choice to avoid perpetuating the vicious cycle of human oppression
and risks, the lives of all humans to save his love. Trinity.
He also somehow has powers in the real world. Now in revolutions,
we see Neo's choice resulting in the matrix,
deteriorating at the hands of agent Smith.
So he now blinded Neo who can still see something strikes a bargain with the
machines.
He will sacrifice himself to destroy agent Smith in exchange for liberating all
the humans from the matrix who want to be.
What about the others?
What others come on and say what out.
Obviously they will be freed before we get there.
The muddled message of the second and third films,
let's revisit one of the most obvious and well-trained interpretations of the
original film in this interpretation Neo's journey from the green tinge and
illusory world of the matrix into the dystopian real world is a version of
Plato's allegory of the cave to summarize a person,
spends their entire life trapped inside a cave where all they see is shadows on
a wall in front of them. But because this is all they've ever known,
they take the shadows to be the one true reality. One day,
that person like Neo is set free to discover the reality behind the shadows for
Play-Doh.
That person was a philosopher and hence would help others free themselves from
the cave. So for Neo, the cave is the matrix and he's led out by Morpheus.
You take the blue pill, the story ends.
You wake up in your bed and believe whatever you want to believe.
You take the red pill, you stay in Wonderland,
and I show you how deep the rabbit hole goes.
Techno dystopian than Plato could have ever imagined. But for both Plato's cave,
dweller and Neo the transition to the actual real world,
isn't easy for a lifelong cave. Dweller.
The sun's soak world is blinding for Neo robots are trying to kill him and food
tastes bad.
Plato's allegory of the cave has inspired countless philosophers for thousands
of years, but there's something uniquely timely about it today.
Now more than ever cultural and political movements seem obsessed with stepping
out of the cave of one's imposed ignorance, whether that's using the matrix,
his own red pill as a metaphor for one's awakening or staying woke people with
radically different politics frame their movement in terms of pulling back the
curtain of social domination. Welcome to the dessert
of the reel in the original film it's hackers that are presented as the brave
souls who are able to use their technical abilities to identify and exploit the
digital cracks in their false reality. And while in the nineties,
the internet was still in its early stages. You've got mail.
The feeling that the right sub Reddit or Google search can set you free from
your ideological shackles has become commonplace.
So if the original matrix film tried to wake us up from our various dream
States, by asking us to question our realities,
how did the sequels try to push this a step further by getting us to wake up
again or in Christopher Nolan's terms?
How can we wake up from a dream that's already taking place within another
dream, besides being pushed into a bathtub of water?
Obviously the matrix reloaded explores the limits of this initial level of
wokeness by showing how larger systems of control are often designed to limit
our freedom. And in particular,
how these systems can control us via the guise of freedom were first introduced
to the central conflict of the film,
the tension between freedom and control during Neo's late night chat with
councilor Hamann about the relationship between seemingly free human beings and
seemingly determined machine.
No I'm here.
Sometimes I think about all those people still plugged into the matrix.
And when I look at this machine,
I can't help thinking that in a way we are plugged into them.
While Neo is quick to point out that humans are ultimately in control as they
can simply hit the off switch councilor Hamann points out the opposite truth
that if they did turn the machines off,
the residents of Zion would no longer have air or water and they would die.
If we control these machines, they don't control us. Of course not.
How could they, the idea is pure nonsense,
but does make one wonder just
what is control.
The appearance of absolute human freedom is a thin veil over an underlying
dependence on machines.
This dichotomy goes even further when Neo meets the architect to inform them
that this is actually the sixth time.
He's had a meeting with an iteration of Neo, how is this possible? Well,
because Neo isn't as free as he thought,
he's actually a necessary feature of the matrix itself. A systemic anomaly.
You are the eventuality of an anomaly, which despite my sincerest efforts,
I've been unable to eliminate from what is otherwise a harmony of mathematical.
Precision.
Is a necessary part of the very system he's working to destroy.
This is very heavy in its implications as the,
which Husky seemed to be implying that even after we wake up from the various
illusions and ideologies,
we still might be caught up in a higher level system of control.
And unfortunately Plato's allegory of the cave is of little use here.
Sometimes raging against the machine is exactly what the machine wants.
And if we want to understand why we need to look to philosopher Karl Marx now
already the ideas of marks map pretty easily onto the matrix.
Marx argued that society had two fundamental classes,
the workers of the world and the owners of capital,
the people who had the actual factories and machines to make stuff who were in
his view, vampires, living off the life force of workers,
tweak this a little bit, and you've got literal machines,
enslaving humans to live off their bodily energy.
While the humans get to dream of eating steak. We should note here that the,
which house,
these thought they were making a movie about the philosophy of John boatyard,
a philosopher who while heavily influenced by Marx greatly diverge from his
ideas in particular boatyard thought that while production Allah Marx's worker
in factory owners was a useful category in analyzing industrial society.
The consumer revolution of the late 20th century made it necessary to shift to
the category of consumption to oversimplify.
Modern capitalism is not so much defined by production lines as it is by Disney
lines, but they got it kind of wrong. Boatyard himself said that the,
which house skis use of his work stemmed mostly from misunderstandings.
He thought the,
which house keys were missing the point in large part because they got trapped
in a Marxist line of thinking marks like Plato thought that most people
experienced an obscured version of reality,
but marks his word for it was ideology, which gets a lot more complicated,
but importantly,
whereas Baudrillard thought there was no deeper reality behind the spectacle of
modern capitalism, no way to escape our metaphorical matrix.
Mark thought that there was hope for piercing.
The veil Marx thought one of the symptoms of ideology was a kind of upside down
world. Whereas many would argue that ideas,
politics and culture are things that drive our material. Reality.
Marx argued that it was the reverse.
Our material reality was what determined our ideas, politics,
and culture to put it simply if you thought your bosses respect for timeliness
and honesty shaped how work was done, you have it backwards. How work is done,
shapes our need for timeliness and honesty for marks,
the foundation of a society is formed by relations of labor and production.
That's called the base. So in an industrial society,
the base is the production of consumer goods,
which requires the distinction between employees and employers or owners and
workers in the matrix.
That base is the need to extract energy from human batteries or whatever it is
they're trying to build or do the place where ideology rests.
He calls the superstructure. It's composed of things like culture, religion,
politics, and rituals in industrial society.
The superstructure helps reinforce base relations like the virtue of hard work,
getting you through the day as you monotonously tighten your thousandth nut for
the day or in the Canon of this bizarre Powerade commercial you're craving of
electrolytes to fuel your robot.
The point is to keep generating all that energy.
Your body needs to be replenished.
So drink your Powerade.
We have quotas to meet.
Superstructure reproduces itself to perpetuate the base conditions. However,
it's not until the matrix revolutions that Neo is able to fully grasp that the
superstructure is not just the matrix.
If human ideology is dictated by the means of machine production.
So is machine ideology.
He meets three programs in the train station named Rama Chondra Kamala and their
daughter Sati and learns that the war oppresses machines too,
as they're trying to help their daughter, if they delete.
I love my daughter very much.
I find it to be the most beautiful thing I've ever seen,
but where we are from that is not enough.
Every program that is created must have a purpose. If it does not,
it is deleted.
Therefore the matrix,
isn't just a system in a sense that it's a computer program.
The superstructure births,
the idea that humans and machines must be perpetually at war to ensure that the
material base of energy production goes untouched. So in an ideological sense,
that is the matrix.
This brings us back to the tension between freedom and control.
As in Marx's analysis,
certain types of freedom are just super structural illusions that enable a
deeper level of control in terms of an economic base.
Remember that Neo's entire existence,
including his role as the one who will lead a rebellion to free humans from
machine control is a necessary part of the system itself.
But the matrix argues it is when one thinks they are free from ideology,
that they are most immersed in it.
I'm going to hang up this phone and then I'm going to show these people what you
don't want them to see. I'm going to show them a world without you,
a world without rules and controls without borders or boundaries.
If we thought Neo threatening his machine overlords and flying off into the sky
as rage against the machine plays was peak rebellion.
We were sorely mistaken and the architect's control room he learns.
He was actually doing precisely what previous versions of his code already done
five times previously, what was already pre-planned.
The function of the one is now to return to the source,
allowing a temporary dissemination of the code. You carry reinserting,
the prime program.
That's precisely what's happening to us when we both consume and produce ideas
and content on digital platforms.
As each time we tweet or repost an article that exposes some societal injustice
or buried knowledge,
we are providing more data for algorithms that are figuring out how to better
serve us ads and sell us goods and services. And unlike Neo,
these illusions are taking place right within our own world.
We're even creating our own myths to avoid acknowledging how wrapped up we are
in these systems. For example, the stories about people's devices,
listening to them and serving them ads on Facebook and Instagram.
This is of course false, but the truth is more horrifying,
which is that algorithms have done such a good job of constructing data sets
about each of us, that they can accurately predict our desires,
which brings us back to the tension between control and freedom.
Are we really free when we exist in digital spaces?
Or are we just the unknowing cogs in a digital marketing machine?
The one was never meant to end anything.
It was all another system of control and why.
While Neo's matrix power,
while seeing gold in the third film still doesn't make sense. Maybe the,
which house were trying to go for something like this,
his powers derived from his ability to see behind the final curtain,
the ideology that dictates the human machine war,
the ability to break through an all encompassing ideological system ends up
being more valuable than the ability to Dodge bullets.
And maybe this is why Lana which house he has said that the themes of the matrix
films are more relevant now than ever as we live in a digital culture that is
obsessed with becoming woke to cultural injustice and red pilling,
their way to higher forms of knowledge. But all too often,
this attempt to wake up from the dream is just a higher function of the very
ideological structure. We think we're escaping.
If there's a consistent theme from these films that applies to this contemporary
problem,
it seems to be the imperative to constantly interrogate ideological systems.
With the understanding that the moment we think ourselves free from ideology is
likely when we are the most fully immersed in it.
So will the next matrix introduce us to some new illusion we've been
indoctrinated into? Will it explain some of the shortcomings of the trilogy?
Honestly, I'm just really, really hoping it's good. In the meantime,
we'll be trying our best to remember that even if we don't have sockets in our
spines,
that we might be plugged into ideological power structures without even knowing
it. So good luck in staying awake and as always, thanks for watching guys.
Peace
[inaudible].